you've mentioned she multiple times I'm
not sure if you saw the breaking news
that Biden is planning on meeting him in
San Francisco in the coming weeks um
obviously this is the most consequential
relationship in the world you've talked
about what's going on with China um
you've talked about Clarity right sort
of the premise of that meeting is they
don't want any surprises they want to
have uh reestablished military
connections or re uh Communications they
want to address climate change they want
to address open borders and drugs and
fentol that's coming across drug
trafficking South chin sea
what do you envision what do you see
happening with Biden and shei next week
or when it happens I think Xi Jinping
will be running circles around Joe
Biden I think it's just it's it's a
capability issue at the top right now in
the United States of America I me the
climate change
agenda is part of what China uses to
laugh at and trample and stomp all over
the face of the United States of America
I mean there's a word in
Mandarin it's called Uh B
you know what it means refers to
Progressive white people in the United
States does apply to me some of you guys
but it's it's it's like it's like a
derisive term how do you say it it's B
AI zuo if you want if you're looking it
up and so I'm not fluent Mandarin but
it'd be something like bis bis something
like
that and
so there it is yeah actually yeah white
Les derogatory Chinese neologism western
leftism western I think I think it's
actually very specific to White in
particular um Adam you're such a baou y
yeah yeah no I don't think so no they're
referring to the kind of people who
support who support Biden actually yeah
so so and and and and to some extent
Biden falls into this category so the
climate change agenda the idea of put
Throne climate change in that this is
the useful idiot yeah in Russia right CU
there the modern version of the useful
idiot idiotic liberals right there
second line so it is it's the Communist
useful idiot from the 1950s so so that
when I hear climate change on that
agenda that's useless for the United
States because that's just a way for
China to run laps around us while we're
flogging
ourselves and you know I think that
that's kind of what they've done on some
of these issues of race and human rights
I mean a couple years ago what was xiin
ping saying black lives matter shows the
United States is no better when he's
questioned about putting a million
religious minorities weers in
concentration camps and subjecting them
to force sterilization and communist
indoctrination and Wars so I think that
because of that self-hatred that exists
in the United States today particularly
on the left China understands the useful
idiot the bito to be able to exploit
that psychological insecurity back
against us and because Biden is so
obsessed with self- flogging the United
States for our modern way of life and
our sins of systemic racism and
everything else dating back to the
apologist agenda that the modern
Progressive left Embraces that puts
China at a competitive advantage in any
discussion that looks like the one
they're about to have my discussion with
shanping would be different yeah I to
know what that would look like you
Unleashed hell on the world with the co
19 pandemic we know it was a lab Lake
you lied about it the only question is
was it
intentional if you don't tell me now we
find out separately there's going to be
even bigger consequences there already
going to
be we know it was intentional because
well here's what it's going to be
Financial consequences of the highest
order using every Financial lever we
have
available if we don't hold you
accountable for that then we know we can
expect worse in the future and I'm not
going to expect worse in the future
Financial consequences using every lever
available up to including the national
debt held by China we will
extract our appropriately due reparation
for the coid 19 pandemic oh by the way
you're not playing by the same set of
rules you're going to be kicking you out
of the
WTO and any sort of relation from a
trade perspective with the US unless
you're playing by the same set of rules
no IP theft no data theft no forced
technology transfers from American
companies no turning our companies into
lobbying pawns none of that until we're
playing by the same set of rules or else
we're done and we're by the time I show
up at that meeting I'm have done my
homework we're already on Shing to the
United States and we've already
bolstered relationships with Japan South
Korea India Australia and otherwise such
that he knows when I'm sitting across
the table from him I'm not not bsing him
right we have a stronger hand than he
does
that's worse for him than it is for us
he knows so then he has to fold and he
knows that but he has to know that when
he shows up which means you got to do
your homework before you show up at that
meeting the other thing I will say is
don't you touch and come
within spitting distance of the idea of
annexing Taiwan anytime in the
foreseeable future because we will
defend at least until we have
semiconductor Independence in this
country because you will not hold an
economic gun to our head I know that's
the wet dream that China has no we're
not going to let you do that it's not
going to happen on my
watch and then after we have
semiconductor Independence we will
resume our current position of strategic
ambiguity and see what that looks like
in the future you know this is what's
scary about this election that no one is
paying attention to it because and what
you you left out I know you didn't leave
it out you just didn't list it there
which is also tie your damn currency to
trade and Float with the international
currency markets right because they
China's manipulator number one in every
different direction but it's not just
the currencies it's manipulation of data
transfers it's manipulation of every set
of rules toally you're correct on every
point I was just adding currency to that
I think that if he if China senses that
there is a conservative Victory with
someone's going to sit at the table and
put those cards down they will move on
China before November 1st of next move
on Taiwan before November 1st of next
year because they have to they need that
because everything you're talking about
here says okay first of all I'm stopping
your repayments now I'm stopping on
trillions of T bills I'm doing this and
this and this they are they are
tightened up so many ways you're so
correct they have to move on Taiwan
before the election if someone like you
is leading in those polls you funny
story I shared this before there was a
former um leader of of another Nation
former head of state was an event uh he
approached me afterwards he said you
know they're not happy that an
indian-american and particularly you is
is running for US president I said oh
you you know that from having known them
he's like no no I know that from knowing
it now I said okay well it's interesting
to know um you know China's you know I
don't think our adversaries are going to
like it very much if you have somebody
who's in office that can't be exploited
in the way that Biden is
however I will give the world our allies
and adversaries and our own citizens the
same message that's what makes it
credible our sole
obligation is to protect US citizens
here at
home see it's interesting how much more
credible are your messages your allies
can take it more seriously your
adversaries can take your red lines more
seriously our citizens can take it more
seriously if actually saying the same
thing to
everybody my sole obligation as the US
president my moral obligation is to the
Americans here at home and everything
that I'm going to draw is a hard Red
Line tracks that and that's how you know
I'm going to keep it and so they will
take it more seriously and I don't think
world war is in China's interest and I
don't think world war is in America's
interest and I don't think it's in
Russia's interest and I don't think it's
in any nation's interest and so the way
we avoid it is by having those clear red
lines clear answers about what we will
and won't do don't drive our adversaries
in different ways into alliances with
one another get Russia out of China's
hands be very clear with our own people
that war is never a preference for us
it's only ever going to be a necessity
that avoiding World War II is a vital
objective and then we protect our own
Homeland enough to say God forbid
there's a major conflict in the future
we know that we're not as vulnerable as
we are today those are the basic next
steps when it comes to foreign policy of
the next US president and then reducing
that economic dependence on China is an
easy win that we can deliver along the
way so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right
here